hello everyone you all know more feet to
be a pretty strong player and here is
the one game to show you just how strong
he really was this game was from 1958
match against the German master out of
Henderson well except it wasn't they did
play a match in 1858 but this was a
casual game this game isn't a part of
the match as well in 1857 a year before
that when more if you really decided to
play chess he decided to participate in
the first American chess congress and he
really crushed the field destroying
Louis Paulsen in the finals and well in
the entire event he lost only one game
but nevertheless it was a magnificent
achievement and well already then people
already started considering Morphy as
the strongest player in the world
although he officially wasn't well not
just yet how our Staunton was the
self-proclaimed champion of the world
and while the people's champion I mean
the person who everyone everyone else
considered to be the greatest player in
the world was the German chess master
Adolph Anderson and well after winning
the first American chess congress Morphy
travelled to England decided to
challenge mr. Stanton but Stanton really
avoided that match he claimed that he
was really ill and what that match never
took place
so morphe decided okay to hell with
England I'm going to France he sailed to
friends and well they're well by
accident at the German master Adolph
Anderson was passing by and the Morphy
decided to challenge him to a match
although morphe did catch a very serious
case of some sort of an intestinal e
intestine intestinal influences sorry
and he was very ill he was treated with
leeches and he lost a lot of blood he
couldn't even stand on his own but
nevertheless he decided that the match
should take place and while they played
a series of 11 games and the result of
that match was well I will tell you
tomorrow as I will do a more fee video
but as for today this is a casual game
this has nothing to do with this match
this is only
intro for tomorrow's video this is a
casual game between Paul Morphy and
adult Anderson also played in 1858 and
it's well it's a really a great game so
let's see this great game Murphy has the
white pieces and the German master
Adolphe Anderson who is considered to be
the strongest player in the world has
the black pieces
Murphy plays efore we have E 5 F for the
King's gambit at Anderson accepts the
gambit of course he captures an F for
Knight to f3 and g5 we have h 4g g4 by
Anderson and Knight to e5 the keys are
ski gambit Knight to f6 and now Knight
captures and g4 we have Knight captures
an e4 by understand now threatening
Knight to g3 but Murphy encourages the
see plays d3 we have Knight to g3
and well now Murphy's rook is attacked
on h1 but Murphy of course has a
brilliant tactical idea here he plays
Bishop captures on f4 sacrifices the
rook but with a well with a with a
brilliant idea that actually favors
black but it's hard for black to play
this Anderson captures the rook as this
is the best move Queen to d2 with check
and here well black has the option of
covering with Queen to e7 or with Bishop
to e7 Bishop d7 would be a terrible
blunder as the Bishop to e7 you get
Knight to f6 with check King to f8 and
Bishop 286 with checkmate this would be
well a rather unfortunate for the German
master
so after Queen to d2 check Anderson
covered up with the Queen to e7 now
Knight to f6 was played with check King
to d8 and now Murphy plays Bishop
captures on c7 with check only move for
Anderson is King actors on c7 and now
comes Knight to d5 with the Royal fork
and well Murphy wins the Queen we have
King to d8 and Knight captures on e7 and
Bishop captures on e7 and after all is 7
done well more if he did win the Queen
but Andres
has two pieces and the rook for the
Queen so well it might be an equal
position but it actually favors black
Queen to g4 by Morphy we have the six
developing and opening up a discovered
attack on morphus Queen Queen to f4 now
eyeing that f7 pawn but Anderson decides
to play the best move rock to GA to
developing Queen captures on f7 and now
Bishop captures on h4 would check by
Anderson King to d8 by morphe we have
rook to e8 and now well morphe does have
the Queen but hey he still has to
develop his pieces and he plays the best
move Knight to a3 pretty much the only
way to develop without losing too much
moves preparing to play rook to e1 and
while getting the night into the game
with Knight to c4 and while this is the
the critical moment in the game well
Anderson still doesn't really have any
problems here with a move like Bishop to
g5 would check he's still in the game as
morphic cannot afford to play King to c1
for example this will result in a
terrible rook to e1 checkmate and if he
goes to King to d1 then Bishop to g4 and
Anderson is winning this without a
problem
so after this Bishop to g5 move morphe
would have to play King to c3 and this
would bring the white king well well in
the range of Anderson's pieces after he
starts developing but for some reason
Anderson didn't find this Bishop to g5 g
v mu which is pretty odd but okay after
night to a3 by morphe Anderson played
night to a6 also decided to develop his
queen side pieces but this allowed
morphic Queen to h5 now attacking this
bishop and while x-raying this night on
h1 if the bishop moves unfortunately
more Anderson cannot save both pieces so
Bishop to f6 was played eyeing the B to
pawn hoping to attack the rook and the
night
morphic captures the knight Queen
captures on h1 Bishop capture some b2
now threatening the rook and the night
but this is actually quite defendable in
the Murphy place the correct sequence
Queen to h4 would check kink to d7 and
now rook to be one would an attack on
the bishop and now Anderson can capture
the knight on a three which he does a
Bishop captures on a three but Murphy
plays Queen to a four with check and
well next move Murphy will grab this
Bishop on a three so in this position
instead of well continuing this game
being so much material down the German
master out of Anderson resigned the game
as after for example King to d8 Queen
captures on a3 is coming and an Anderson
is simply down too much material he
resigns the game so yeah this is just a
prelude to tomorrow's video a video
where I will tell you a bit more about
this spectacular match and well show you
at least one game maybe even two from
the match more if you played against the
German master and well it's it's quite
an epic match definitely you know it can
be rival two with a match like alien
versus Capablanca or Fischer Spassky
versus Fischer or you know one of those
epic matches that took place in chess
history so yeah that the video I do hope
you enjoyed it as well I know how much
all of you love Morphy and well he is
playing against the strongest player in
the world and practically the guy who
invented immortal games so should be
should be quite a fun match and I would
like to thank
well a person who decided to remain
unknown but he did make a contribution
to my channel so I do thank you a lot
and I really appreciate it thank you
very much sir as usual you can check to
my previous videos here I think all for
my for watching and I will see you soon